[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلنت المقاومه الشعبيه في اليمن
انها تقترب من السيطره على محافظه ابين
بعدما احكمت سيطرتها بمساعده وحدات عسكريه
على محافظات عدن والضالع ولحج في الوقت
الذي تحرز فيه تقدما في تعز نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين ما هي
التاثيرات المحتمله الانقلاب ميزان القوه
الميدانيه لصالح الشرعيه على طرفي الصراع
في
اليمن وكيف سينعكس هذا الانقلاب في موازين
القوه على الارض على احتمالات التسويه
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
للازمه خلال ايام فقط انقلبت موازين القوه
بالكامل لصالح المقاومه الشعبيه والوحدات
العسكريه التابعه للحكومه الشرعيه في
اليمن فباتت تنتقل من نصر الى اخر حتى
سيطرت على ثلاث محافظات ليس هذا فحسب بل
ان سيطره المقاومه على بقيه البلاد باتت
بنظر الكثير من المراقبين مجرد مساله وقت
وضع سيؤثر بلا شك على اطراف الازمه
اليمنيه وعلى طبيعه النهايه المحتمله هذه
الازمه هل بات وصول المقاومه الشعبيه الى
صنعاء وشيكا لا شك ان الطريق الى العاصمه
اليمنيه الخاضعه لسيطره ميليشيا الحوث منذ
سبتمبر ايلول الماضي اسهل من اي وقت مضى
بعد السيطره على قاعده العند الاستراتيجيه
في محافظه لحج تمكنت المقاومه الشعبيه
المدعومه من التحالف الذي تقوده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من احراز تقدم في جبهات
اخرى مشتعله وفق اخر الام بسط المقاومه
سيطرتها الكامله على محافظه ابين مساله
شبه محسومه وقد تلتحق قريبا ابين
بالمحافظات الخاضعه لسيطره المقاومه
الداعمه لشرعيه الرئيس هادي وهي حتى الان
عدن ولحج والضالع اغارت طائرات التحالف
خلال الساعات الماضيه على عده مواقع
للحوثيين في حرد وجبل النار في حجه شمال
غرب اليمن وايضا البيضاء في وسط البلاد
بعد شهور من المعارك الطاحنه يبدو ان
موازين القوه غيرت لترجح كفه الانتصارات
لصالح المقاومات الشعبيه امام تقلص مساحه
تمدد ميليشيا الحوثي قاعده العند الجويه
لا شك ان الانتصار في معركه قاعده العند
الجويه ساهم بشكل كبير في قطع طرق الامداد
لميليشيا الحوث والقوات المواليه للرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح كما ان القاعده
امنت الطريق للمقاومه بين محافظات عدن
ولحج والضالع وتعز التقدم العسكري الاخير
قد ين ينعكس على الجانب السياسي للازمه
اليمنيه ذات التفاصيل المعقده والابعاد
الاقليميه العديده هل ستستمر المعارك
ويحدد السلاح وحده من يحكم صنعاء ام ان
الحوثيين سيطالبون بمفاوضات بسقف مطالبه
اقل من تلك التي ذهبوا بها الى جنيف في
يونيو الماضي بعد كل هذه الدماء والخسائر
في الممتلكات هل ثمت امكانيه لحل سياسي
وعلى اي اساس سيكون ما هو مؤكد ان المعارك
على الارض مستعره والانتصارات الاخيره
للمقاومه الشعبيه تمهد الطريق لعوده
الرئيس الشرعي قد يعود الرئيس هادي الى
يمن غيرته الحرب كثيرا واصلاح ما افسده
الصراع لن يكون مهمه
يسيره لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الرياض راجح بادي المتحدث باسم الحكومه
اليمنيه ومن صنعاء عبد الوهاب الشرفي
الكاتب والباحث السياسي وعبر الهاتف من
عدن علي الاحمدي المتحدث الرسمي باسم مجلس
المقاومه في عدن وابدا مع علي الاحمدي هل
هذه الانتصارات
نهائيه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اسعد الله
مسائكم جميعا بالخير والمسرات
الانتصارات هذه هي امتداد لتحرير مدينه
عدن ثم محافظه لحج و لا ادري ما المقصود
من معنى النهائيه هي
انتصارات حسم الامور بشكل كامل بمعنى هل
هي معرضه لكرو وفر مجددا يعني هل هي ه
الانتصار الذي اعلنتم عنه مؤمن او هنالك
فرص اخرى لتقدم الحوثيين وقوات
صالح طبعا مساله تحرير المناطق التي تمت
في عدن اعقبها ايضا عمليه لتامين الخطوط
الدفاعيه بشكل قوي ومتين بحيث لا يمكن ان
يحصل اختراق مجددا
او علما ان الميليشيات الحوثيه في اوعظ
حالاتها الان هي تبحث عن سلامه الراس وعن
الدفاع في عقر معقلها يعني الاصلي لذلك
فكره انها تتمدد من جديد هذه غير وارده
لكن رغم ذلك نحن في عدن الحكومه الشرعيه
والجيش الموالي
للشرعيه عاون مع المقاومه عمدوا الى تعزيز
الخطوط الدفاعيه
وتامين المناطق التي حررت بشكل قوي ومتين
ان شاء الله ضيفي من صنعاء عبد الوهاب
الشرفي برايك ما هو
انعكاس انقلاب ميزان القوه
لصالح القوات
الشرعيه بدايه مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك ولس
الساده المشاهدين الكرام
ا هو ربما يصعب توصيف القضيه بان هناك
حاله انقلاب موازين مطلقه ربما كما قلنا
ان ال ال يعني 100 اكثر من 1230 يوما
يعتبر فتراها ربما هي طويله التي يستطاع
ان يحافظ هناك اللجان الشعبيه على قتال في
تلك الاراضي التي قلنا هي بطبيعتها غير
قابله لوجو
هيه الجنوبيه المفتوح سيد الشرفي ل نختصر
لان الوقت يداهمنا هنالك تقدم ل لقوات على
حساب قوات اخرى انا اريد ان اعرف هذا
التقدم الذي وصف بالانتصار لجهه على حساب
جهه اخرى كيف يؤثر على كل طرف من اطراف او
من طرفي النزاع
الحالي على كل حال هو نحن نقترب الان ربما
اكثر من
قضيه توجه كل الاطراف الان لتضع قضيه
الخيار السياسي كخيار اكثر حظا مما مضى
على اعتبار انه جوهر المشكله القائمه هي
ليست المعركه وانما قضيه مؤسسه الرئاسه
والمؤسسه الحكوميه ووضع الجيش والمؤسسات
الاداريه وبالتالي ربما خلال الفتره
الماضيه نتيجه الاندفاع لانصار الله جنوبا
ربما جعل صوت المعركه هو الاعلى لكن نحن
الان نقترب اكثر انه في الاخير يجب ان
ينصع الجميع لحل سياسي على اعتبار انه لا
يمكن ان تحل القضيه الا بحل سياسي طيب
انتقل الى ضيفي راجح بادي من الرياض سيد
راجح باعتقادك ما هي التحديات التي ستكون
امام كل طرف في في حال انعكست التطورات
العسكريه على التطورات السياسيه ما هو
التحدي امام كل طرف سياسيا
ايضا مساء الخير سيدتي ال الكريمه نحن
حقيقه في الحكومه تحدثنا منذ بدايه هذه
الكارثه التي حلت باليمن بسبب ميليشيات
الحوثي وصالح اننا مع حل سياسي نحن كدوله
وحكومه ضد كل ما يجري من اعمال دمار وقتل
وتشريد تحدثنا دعونا لاحلال السلام اي
والاستقرار في اليمن لكن الطرف الاخر كان
متعنتا نتيجه امتلاكه للقوه لكن الان عقب
ال التقدم الكبير لقوات الجيش الوطني
والمقاومه
الشعبيه الباسله اصبح الان ربما ان الملعب
مفتوح لحل سياسي ان فهم الطرف الاخر وتعقل
واراد ان يجنبنا دفع المزيد من من فاتوره
باهضه تتحملها اليمن لكننا هنا ك حكومه
شرعيه نؤكد ان الحل السياسي ممكن وفقا
لقرار مجلس الامن 2 216 الذي رفض الحوثي
حتى هذه اللحظه تنفيذ رغم انه نتحدث بشكل
واضح انه خلال اليومين الماضيين تقدمت عدد
من الشخصيات السياسيه وربما عدد من
الاطراف الدوليه بمساعي سياسيه للتوصل الى
تسويه مقابل رفع العقوبات عن زعيم حركه
الحوثيين عبد الملك الحوثي و وتفاصيل اخرى
ليس من المصلحه الان الكشف عنها لكننا
اكدنا
كحكومة لابد من تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن 2
21 6 اذا اردنا فعلا واراد المجتمع الدولي
والامم المتحده ان تحقق الامن والاستقرار
في اليمن فلا بد من تنفيذ هذا القرار
كمنظومه متكامله
وليس كزات من هذا القرار كما تطرح بعض
الاطراف الاقليميه طيب ثمت انباء انك كما
علمنا عدت اليوم من عدن كما رايت الوضع
الميداني هناك بام عينيك الى اي حد يوائم
الوضع الذي رايته انت هناك معيشيا وعسكريا
واقتصاديا وضع الناس العاديين وضع تقدم
المقاومه الوضع عدن الى اي حد يوائم ما
يجري الحديث عنه من حلول
سياسيه حقيقه انا عدت قبل ساعات قليله من
من مدينه عدن التي ضربت يعني صور نادره في
التضحيه والصمود تجاه العدوان الحوثي على
مدينه عدن ومدينه عدن انا اؤكد الان وعلى
منبر الجزيره ان الحديث حول استعادتها
وامنها حديث منتهي تماما الان نحن في طور
في طور تحرير المثلث الاستراتيجي المحيط
بعدن وهو مثلث ابين تعز لحج اليوم تم
استعاده محافظه لحج بشكل كامل خلال الايام
القليله القادمه وكما اكدنا على الجزيره
سابقا ان لحج ستحرر انا اؤكد هنا ومن على
قناه الجزيره ان محافظه ابين ستحرر ان لم
يكن خلال الساعات القليله القادمه سيتم
تحريرها خلال ايام قليله جدا وبالتالي
الانطلاق الى راس المثلث الاستراتيجي وهو
وهو محافظه وهو محافظه تعز عدن يعني الناس
الناس هناك تواقين للدوله تواقين للعيش
بامن واستقرار السلطه المحليه الان تدير
المحافظه بشكل بشكل كامل الامن مستتب لا
وجود لاي اعمال تخريب الادعاءات التي كان
يتحدث عنها الحوثي انه من يستلم السلطه في
حال انسحب من هذه المحافظات ابناء عدن هم
من يديرون عدن ويقدمون صور رائعه في في
فرض الامن والاستقرار داخل داخل المدينه
والتعايش بين كل طبقات المجتمع داخل داخل
مدينه عدن وهذا يؤكد ان مشكله ان مشكله
اليمن هو الحوثي اينما وجد الحوثي وجدت
وجد الاقتتال وجد القتل وجد الدمار نعم
تفضلي انا سالتك انك كنت في عدن وتفضلت وق
قلت سعدت من ساعات وسالتك عن مدى موائمه
ما شاهدته هناك ما عاينته مع ما يجري
الحديث عنه من حلول سياسيه وهذه الحلول
والتحديات مع ما يكتنفها من امور معقده
داخليا وارتباطات خارجيه في في يعني فيما
رايته هل يمكن
مثلا حل مساله تحدي امام مثلا دمج
المقاومه مع الجيش الوطني كل هذا هل هل
سيكون
سهلا
بالتاكيد ما سالتي عنه خاصه دمج رجال
المقاومه الابطال في في الجيش الوطني او
في قوات الشرطه نحن التقينا برجال
المقاومه من كافه الفصائل ومن كافه
التيارات لانه كما تعلمين عدن بجميع
ابنائها هي التي قاومت بشكل رئيسي هناك
ترحيب بهذه الخطوه الكل يريد دوله الكل لا
يريد وجود سلاح في مدينه عدن مدينه عدن هي
حاضره المدن
اليمنيه وهي المدينه الاكثر مدنيه في في
في اليمن الكل لا يريد حمله السلاح الكل
يريد ان ينخرط في مؤسسات الجيش وفي مؤسسات
الشرطه بشكل نظامي الكل مع مع مع سلام
واستقرار انا اؤكد انه الحل السياسي ربما
نجد فيه صعوبه في اقناع ابناء المقاومه
الذين قدموا تضحيات كبيره هناك من قدم
يعني اكثر من شهيد من اسره واحده هناك من
دمر منزله هناك من انتهت تجارته داخل
مدينه عدن لذلك سنجد صعوبه في اقناع هذه
الاطراف التي قامت بتضحيات كبيره بهذا
الحل السياسي لكننا اؤكد مره اخرى ان
الجميع يعني في هذه اللحظه ربما يكون الحل
السياسي القائم على القرار 2 س ربما يجنب
اليمن مزيد من الدمار ولعل عدن لو
شاهدتيها بام عينيك ورايتي الدمار الذي
وجدتي فيها انا عندما كنت امشي في بعض
شوارع عدن وخاصه في مدينه دار سعد كنت
كاني اتجول في حلب وليس في مدينه يمنيه من
حجم الدمار واليمنيين يتسائلون هذا الدمار
والحوثي ليس لديه طيران وليست لديه مدفعيه
ثقيله فكيف لو كان يمتلك الطيران كيف كان
سيكون حجم الدمار داخل مدينه طر الاخر
دمره سيقول لديه جواب على ذلك
يعني سيدتي الكريمه من توجه الى مدينه عدن
بسلاحه وعدته وعتاده هو من يتحمل مسؤوليه
مسؤوليه الدمق مع
الحب من يبدا من يبدا بالطلقه الاولى هو
من يتحمل مسؤوليه الدمار ساعود اليكم
ضيوفي الكرام لكن بعد فاصل قصير ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا من جديد اهلا بكم مباشره الى صنعاء
مع عبد الوهاب الشرفي سدي الشرفي الى اي
مدى ترى بان قوات صالح
والحوثيين لازالوا لازالوا ميدانيا
متماسكين بمعنى انه هنالك انباء تقول بان
هنالك حالات فرار من جانب قوات انصار الله
او الحوثيين وهنالك تمرد من شخصيات معينه
كانت الى جانب قوات صالح الى اي حد هم
متماسك واذا لم يكونوا متماسكين هل من
الممكن القبول كما قال ضيفي من الرياض
بالقرار 2 اوا
س بالنسبه للجزء الاول من السؤال مع اني
لم اسمع السؤال بشكل جيد لكن
لا ادري انا التفاصيل ليس هناك مؤشرات تدل
على ان هناك حاله عدم تمسك باديه يعني
عليهم ربما هو كما قلت لك التاثير الذي
انعكس عليهم هو تاثير انعكاس هم المفاجئ
لكن حاله التماسك لا تزال باديه بالنسبه
للسؤال الاخر هو او للجزء الاخر من السؤال
الحقيقه انه الموضوع يجب ان يوصف بشكل
سليم بالنسبه للشرعيه الشرعيه هي ليس
جينات وليست لا تاتي من الخارج بحيث نظل
نتحجج بالقرار الاممي الشرعيه في الاخير
هي حاله تفويض من المكونات الوطنيه اذا
استطاعت الرئاسه الحاليه ان تقدم محفزات
بالنسبه لمكون صالح ومكون انصار الله
بالشكل الذي يعيدها الى ان تقدم تفويضها
او تعيد تفويضها للرئيس هادي للاستمرار
لباقي الفتره الانتقاليه في هذه الحاله
يمكن ان توصف بالش يه ما لم فهي تحصل ايضا
اذا لم توافق ه هذين المكونين فهي تحصل
على جزء من المكونات او جزء من التفويض
بالشرعيه وهذا الامر لا يمنعها حق ان
تتصرف بالكامل او ان تحتج بالقرار الاممي
في الاخير هناك ازمه حقيقيه في البلد حول
مؤسسه الرئاسه يجب ان يجلس الجميع للتفاوض
حولها اما ان يقنع انصار الله وصالح
الاطراف الاخرى بان تتحول الى شخصيه اخرى
تغطي هذه المؤسسه الرئاسه او ان تتمكن
الاطراف الاخرى من ان تقنع الطرف انصار
الله وطرف صالح بان تستمر الرئاسه الحاليه
الذي هي متمثله في الرئيس هذه للفتره
القادمه مقابل ضوابط اداء معينه يمكن ان
تفرض عليها نعم اشعر بان هذه الاجابه يعني
كانها اجابه من الارشيف وكانني طرحت عليك
سؤال قبل ان تجري السيطره من قبل
الحوثييين على صنعاء وكان هنالك الكثير من
الشد والجد سياسيا تحول بعده الى اقتحام
من قبل الحوثيين لصنعاء لكن اجابتك تصلح
لهذه الفتره الان سالت الكثير من الدماء
وهنالك تقدم للمقاومه ولقوات المواليه
للحكومه الشرعيه المعترف بها
دوليا هل يجوز التمسك بنفس الشروط يا سي
يا
سيدتي يا سيدتي الكريمه المساله ليست فقط
قضيه اندفاع انصار الله نحن كان لدينا
مؤسسه رئاسه ولدينا حكومه هي نفسها يجب ان
تسائل عن شغلها لهذه المواقع دون قيامها
بوظائفها هي كانت تتحول الى عمليه اقتطاع
للحصص وزياده تمكين
للافراد من طرفها في الوظائف وما اليه جذب
مؤسسه الجيش باتجاهها لتحقيق مصالح نفوذه
وكانت تترك مهامها ووظائفها على جنب
وبالتالي من هنا نحن نقول ان المساله
جرى اجترار مرات عده هذا الكلام سيد
الشرفي وتخط الزمن بعدما سيطر انصار الله
او الحوثيون على كل الدوله على العاصمه
سيطروا عليها يعني اذا كانوا مظلومين
بامور معينه بالدوله
امتلعب الرد بان صارت حرب الان الامور
تخطت هذا هذه المواضيع التي تطرحها الى حد
ان من ينتصر على الارض بالسلاح هو من يفرض
شروطه وعلى ما يبدو الحوثيون ليسوا
منتصرين فعلى اي اساس تقول لي انهم
سيعودون الى تلك الشروط التي سبق عندما
عندما تبهم عندما تتمكن القو عندما تتمكن
القوات الطرف الاخر من من من الوصول الى
صنعاء والسيطره الى صنعاء يمكن ان نبني
على بالنسبه للطرح الذي تطرحه وايضا ستقوم
حاله لا شرعيه في الاخير لاعتبار انه جزء
من المكونات هي غلبت كما غلبت الان جزء من
المكونات التي تقوم هذه الصراع الان على
خلفيتها ان هناك اطراف هي مغلوبه فاذا
سلمنا بهذا المبدا مبدا الواقع من يفرض
الواقع في الاخير حتى وان وصلوا الى صنعاء
ستظل الازمه موجوده ربما تخمد لفتره ربما
ذا لكن ستعود الانفجار في البلد الى
الجديد من جديد ما هو مطلوب هو ان يستوعب
الجميع ان حاله الشرعيه القائمه في البلد
هي حاله يجب ان تكون حاله توافقيه من
الجميع هذا دخليا لكن هك تفا حدثت ايض
ويرت ايض من مسار الامور هنك اتفاق نووي
حدث مع
ايران بعد جرى الانسحاب من عدن كليا
والبعض ربط بذلك
لاي لا يمكن على الاطلاق نحن ان نسلم بان
العامل الخارجي هو احد العوامل فيما يتعلق
بالشرعيه مطلقا ربما يصبح محفزا لاطراف
معينه ان تتعامل مع شرعيه معينه لكن ان
نجعل رغبه الخارج او تفاهمات الخارج او
ومصالح الخارج هي عامل من عوامل وجود او
قيام شرعيه في بلد ما هذا الكلام لا منطقي
على الاطلاق بالعكس ربما ا المسائل وسلمنا
بهذا الامر وصلت فكرتك اشكرك سيد علي
الاحمدي الى اي حد انتم كمقاوم عسكريه
داخليه يمكن ان تلتزموا باي اتفاق حل
سياسي نحن ملتزمون
بما تصل اليه
الشرعيه
وتقرر ولكن انا اتكلم واقعيا ام ان هذه
الجماعه اثبتت انها جماعه لا يمكن ان تصل
الى اي حلول سياسيه الى اي نقاط تقارب
فكرها
ديني
ايديولوجي يريد فرض سياده عرق وجماعه
معينه ولا يقبل الا القوه ولا يدعن الا
للقوه كما نرى من كلام الضيف ان انه لا
يمكن ان يعترفوا بالهزيمه الا اذا دخلت
القوات الى
صنعاء نحن في عدن وان شاء الله باقي مناطق
الجنوب وان شاء الله تعز ومب هذه المناطق
ستحسم امرها وتطبق قرار مجلس الامن بالقوه
يعني بمعنى نحن انا طوال فتره طويله
الحكومه الشرعيه كانت ناشدهم بتطبيق
القرار وسحب القوات والمليشيات لم ينسحبوا
نحن في عدن صدقنا القرار بالقوه وهو الحل
الوحيد الذي نجع مع هذه الميليشيا كذلك
يجب ان يحصل في تعز كذلك في مارب مناطق
الجنوب شبه الان تكون حررت و تطبق فيها
القرار بالفرض الامر الواقع هذه الميليشيا
لن تقبل اي حلول سياسيه كونها انشئت على
فكر ايديولوجي ولا يمكن ان ان ان ان ان
تسير في اي مسار
سياسي الا بالقوه
ان يسحب منها السلاح ان يعود الحوثيون
وينخرط في احزاب سياسيه وهذا امر لا تقبله
النفسيه والعقليه الحوثيه التي هي فكره
ايديولوجيه سياديه تريد ان تحكم وترى انه
حق
مقدس المنتسبين لهذه الجماعه ان يكونون هم
الحكام الان كما قلت نحن الكره في ملعب
اليع المناطق ال سد علي الاحمدي السيد
الشرفي قال شيئا مهما قال حتى ولو جرى
الانتصار عسكريا الان وكبت الامور او حتى
لو جرت التسويه لكن ان لم تكن هذه التسويه
عادله
وتعطي الحوثيين ما بعض مما يطلبون او
تعطيهم ما يراه هو حقوقهم سوف تخمد الان
وتعود مجددا المشكله في اليمن اذا ينبغي
بالنسبه اليه معالجه المشكله من
جذورها نعم انا
برايي الشخصي ان الحركه الحوثيه قد قضت
على اي مستقبل سياسي لها عليهم ان كانوا
يريدون البقاء
في الملعب السياسي ان يشكلوا حزب سياسي
وينخرط في العمليه السياسيه لكن بهذه
الفكر وهذه الايديولوجيا وهذه الطريقه
والسياح والقتل والدماء والدمار الذي حصل
لا لا يمكن ان ان يبقون مع التاكيدي
ويعني بشده ان العنف لا يحل
القضايا الفكريه وقضايا سيد راجح بادي
اختم معك لكي اسالك عن طبيعه التسويه
الممكنه ام ان السلاح وحده سيحدد المستقبل
ام ان التفاهمات والابعاد الاقليميه
المعقده وما جرى الايام الاخيره من
اتفاقات وتفاهمات دوليه هو من سيحدد
ايضا نحن كطرف حكومه وكطر دوله حريصين على
تسويه سياسيه لكن انا اشاطر واشارك الاخ
عبد الوهاب الشرفي انه اي تسويه قادمه
ربما لن تصمت كثيرا لعده عوامل ولعل
العامل الاساسي يعني لكي اذا اردنا ان
نضمن تسويه حقيقيه فعلا تخمد الصراع الى
ابعد مدى فانا اعتقد انه الضمانه الحقيقيه
هو تطبيق قرار مجلس الامن 2 اوا سته
كمنظومه متكامله دون دون اي تسويه لا تقوم
على هذا الاساس سنكون كمن يؤجل مرحله
الصراع الى مرحله اخرى وينفجر الصراع في
قادم الايام بشكل اعنف وبشكل اشمل لا قدر
الله هذه نقطه النقطه الاخرى انه اي انا
اتفق مع الاخ علي الاحمدي عندما اتحدث انه
اي تسويه سياسيه مع الحوثيين هم دائما
ينقذوها انا اضرب مثل اتفاق السلم
والشراكه سيدتي الكريمه عندما تمكن
الحوثيين من اقتحام العاصمه صنعاء وسيطروا
عليها هم من صاغوا بنود اتفاق السلم
والشراكه وارغم جميع القوى السياسيه
بالتوقيع على هذا الاتفاق الذي ن صاغوه
وفي الاخير لم ينفذوا هم ما عليه من
التزامات في هذا الاتفاق لذلك نحن لابد من
تطبيق قرار مجلس الامن كمنظومه متكامله
لكي نحل المشكله في اليمن ما لم فان اللغه
التي يفهمها هي القوه ونحن مستعدون لاي
خيارات اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض راجح
بادي المتحدث باسم الحكومه اليمنيه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر واشكر من صنعاء عبد الوهاب
الشرفي الكاتب والباحث السياسي وعبر
الهاتف اشكر من عدن علي الاحمدي المتحدث
الرسمي باسم مجلس المقاومه في عدن الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء